Tick Tock sensation and gen Zed
influencer Charlie demilio Rose to
International Fame by dancing and lip
syncing on Tick Tock she's since become
the second most followed person on Tick
Tock starred in two television series
with her family and Big Sis won first
place on Dancing With the Stars and is
now jump starting her singing and acting
career with a new single and a lead role
in an upcoming Thriller she is proof of
the overwhelming power of social media
and today this Millennial is going to
take a page from the Gen Z book and
follow along with what Charlie demilio
eats in a day hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
I'll be eating like Tick Tock star
Charlie demilio but I mean not quite
because my needs are unique I'm a little
older than our girl Charlie but I'm
gonna be using her alleged meals as a
template for teaching gentle nutrition
and inspiring what I make that works for
my body and me also a reminder that this
diet was compiled from primary and
secondary sources so ultimately I can't
speak to its legitimacy or accuracy also
this is just what I ate on a random day
and it's never meant to be copied or
recommended as how you should eat so
always speak to registered dietitian
about your unique needs also guys if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button and also follow me on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen oh
we're rolling don't mind me just
procrastinating as per usual playing my
new favorite game island quest away
honestly this is way more addictive than
following the Royal gossip on my Tick
Tock feed so little background are for
you this is an adventure game for web
Android or iOS that has got amazing
reviews the main part of the game is
about a brave girl named Emily she goes
searching for her brother who has
completely disappeared on a mysterious
island together you have to explore the
Territory full of secrets solve many
Mysteries and find out what this
mystical Island actually hides and where
the brother actually is in parallel you
have the opportunity to create your own
unique Farm on the ocean shore you get
to grow vegetables start your own
production and will also be able to make
this place as cozy as you'd like just
look at how you get to decorate the farm
I have a real passion for design
especially when there's such a variety
of Decor elements and the cuteness
factor of the farm animals is a real
bonus I've really never seen anything
like it in an online game the games and
events on this island are unique and
diverse and they regularly offer cool
prizes like I even got myself a pony a
pink pony there's also mini games pepper
throughout the game so even if you're
playing it daily there's always
something new to explore so if you want
to check out island quest way yourself
you can check out my link in the
description box or scan the QR code and
get an impressive pack of 20 diamonds
150 coins and 230 energy points now
before we dive into breakfast let's give
a background on Charlie's relationship
with food so Charlie has been very vocal
about her eating disorder history and
even released a candid statement to her
Instagram expressing how challenging and
uncomfortable it's being to come to
terms with her own experience but since
then she's made a point to use her
platform to really open up about her
experience and Challenge online body
shaming so for example in a campaign
with UNICEF to an online bullying she
shared her struggle with maintaining a
healthy relationship with food and her
body when she was at the receiving end
of online body shaming she's fatter than
when we got her famous or she's ugly
they don't like the way my face looks
for some reason a lot about my body
shape my body type which it's close to
home because I struggled a lot with body
image body dysmorphia bad eating habits
her experience of being told that she
was fatter than before the internet made
her famous was contrasted with her
sister Dixie's experience of being told
that she was too skinny and should eat a
burger and this is the perfect example
of how challenging it is for young women
and teens to love and accept their
bodies as they grow and develop
especially under the careful eye of
millions of followers online not
surprisingly la lots of research
suggests that social media is strongly
associated with the prevalence of
disordered eating and body
dissatisfaction but as Charlie discussed
in her video right here with the help of
a strong support system she's turned a
corner in her relationship with her body
and food and is often encouraging her
young followers to find little ways to
safely do the same so that said it's
time for your girl to eat Abby get at me
first things first coffee and it
wouldn't be a Charlie demellio video
without a nod to her Dunkin Donuts cold
brew collab the Charlie but because
Dunkin Donuts is like virtually
non-existent here in Canada I'm gonna
try to like MacGyver a similar recipe on
my Starbucks app so we're gonna do uh
cold brew oh they have like a salted
caramel cold brew which sounds
interesting and delicious so we need a
cold brew because that's kind of the
base of her drink and she apparently has
like a caramel drizzle and caramel sauce
or it's like a combination of caramel
syrup and caramel sauce going on there's
a lot of caramel is all I know so I'm
just gonna put all the caramel in this
gonna get the salted caramel cream cold
brew with some milk and caramel drizzle
and caramel brulee sauce and caramel
syrup done I feel like this is
definitely something I would have
ordered when I was like
15.
yep she's sweet delicious like really
delicious yum but I feel like this is
like a mid-morning to afternoon drink
it's like a pick me up uh not sure this
is gonna feel so great to my bod all on
its own first thing in the morning
without anything else in there so let's
put it together into a balanced meal
okay let's talk breakfast and I'm super
excited about this because according to
Charlie's Tick Tock account Lucky Charms
is like her go-to morning meal ditto for
her sister Dixie and I can definitely
get on board with that because let's be
real Lucky Charms is like the best
cereal of life I grew up on this and
this one's gone new magic gems what I
love all the limited editions I should
have got the family sized now if I'm
honest I'm 35 years old I'm not eating
Lucky Charms every single day for
breakfast because it's just not gonna
fill me up but it's also not toxic or
poison like we've got nine grams of
sugar and two grams each of fiber and
protein it's really not that bad folks
we can all calm down not to mention it
is fortified with 35 of your iron and
like tons of B vitamins so yeah I really
don't see this as like complete empty
calories but I know all the
nutritionists on Tick Tock are going to
be up in arms about all of the toxic and
ingredients Abby can we go over this
please happy to so one of the first
things to note when taking a look at an
ingredient list of a product is the
order in which the ingredients are
listed and what this basically tells us
is that the ingredients that are listed
at the top are used in higher amounts
compared to ingredients listed further
down the list so when we look at Lucky
Charms cereal we can see that whole
grain oats is listed first and sugar is
listed second so this tells us that
there is a higher amount of sugar
contained in the cereal compared to the
other ingredients used which are down
below and obviously there are other
cereal varieties with a lot less sugar
if that's something of concern to you
but I also think it's helpful to put
this into the context of a varied diet
so for example we're getting nine grams
of sugar per three quarters of cup of
Lucky Charms which is actually less than
half the amount of sugar you would get
from the same quantity of flavored
sweetened Greek yogurt and from most Pro
protein bars I'm not suggesting that we
consume boxes and boxes of cereal like
this but if we're adding a little bit of
sugar sweetened cereal to a balanced
meal I really don't think it's a big
deal as we go further down the
ingredient list we also see vegetable
oils like canola and sunflower now I've
got a whole video on the research on
vegetable oils which you can watch right
here but in short there tends to be a
lot of fear mongering around vegetable
oils and inflammation the larger body of
high quality evidence suggests that the
omega-6s in vegetable oils don't
actually have a significant effect in
fact there's even some interesting
research that they may actually help to
reduce cardiovascular disease not to
mention some seed oils like canola
actually have a very favorable omega-3
to omega-6 ratio so don't believe
everything that you see on Tick Tock now
I finally do want to speak to the use of
food colors and dyes now this concern
may have some Merit in some cases for
some folks who may have have like a food
intolerance or allergy or sensitivity to
certain food dyes now I've got a whole
video on the topic which you can check
out right here but in short one of the
biggest concerns around food dyes is
that they may increase hyperactivity in
kids and while some research suggests
that it may cause some slight increases
in hyperactivity most evidence suggests
that this may be genetically determined
as not all children will react the same
way as far as other health concerns like
cancer risk aside from the dye red 3
which has been largely overtaken by red
40 as is the case in Lucky Charms we
have no quality evidence in humans to
confirm that food dyes pose any
significant risk at the end of the day
most food dyes are contained in a lot of
these highly processed high sugar foods
like Lucky Charms I don't necessarily
recommend going through boxes of things
like Lucky Charms every week but as an
occasional nostalgic experience I don't
see any significant can't harm oh
those kids that have to be Lucky Charms
okay folks let's not complicate things
I've got some full fat plain Greek
yogurt this is going to add tons of
protein plus some fats in there and
since we've got the sugar coming from
our cereal I don't feel like I need
extra Sweetness in the yogurt too but
that's a personal preference I don't
like things super sweet gonna add in
some ripe berries I got a nice melange
oops run away
maybe some banana some hemp hearts for
some healthy fats fiber protein all the
good stuff and of course our BFF Lucky
Charms I am going to
personally try to get all the unicorns
should I save these for the kids
tough mom decision so I think I should
all right so let's give a good handful
trying to get some of the marshmallows a
nice marshmallow to what are they called
like Brody what is this thing called
like a alphabet what is this supposed to
be just the plain the plain bits that
the kids don't like but us adults still
appreciate and this is my little hack I
always mix cereals do you guys mix
cereals I always make cereals this is my
current favorite I don't know if you
guys can get it in the states it is
um manufactured here in Canada but I'm
obsessed with it because it's got seven
grams of sugar but six grams of fiber
and three grams of protein and this is
also fully plant-based I'm like really
obsessed with it it's my favorite cereal
right now so I'm mixing I've got like a
little bit of everything going on a
little bit of that a little bit of this
let's talk about it we've got tons of
protein and healthy fats in our Greek
yogurt we have lots of fiber in all that
fruit plus our cereal that I threw in
there healthy fats on our hemp parts and
we got rainbow marshmallows rainbow come
on oh my gosh make sure we get all these
things
hello a double rainbow we got a double
rainbow here folks check that out
it's gonna be a good day
oh
okay I have a lot of energy now between
the caramel and the coffee and the Lucky
Charms like I think it is time to get in
some joyful movement and considering
that our girl Charlie is like the OG
Tick Tock dancer what better way to get
that movement in other than an
embarrassingly bad dance Montage Lord
help me
what
[Music]
a lot of that
I quit
all right got a little work done let's
talk about lunch so like most teenagers
Charlie loves her fast food particularly
McDonald's nuggets
so much so that she actually stops by
McDonald's for like a chicken McNugget
appetizer on her way to dinner at Nobu
I got four nuggets and a Sprite
four nuggets that's it yeah so you're
about to have McDonald's before you go
eat at Noble yeah really and she even
asked for dino nuggets instead of a chef
prepared paella in her controversial
dinner guest video I mean that kind of
hurts my foodie heart just a little bit
but your girl also loves a good nug so
I'm gonna pull Charlie and Order myself
some Mickey D's and then try to like
Gussy it up into a somewhat balanced
meal all right let's throw some apples
down
we got our nugs look at that one two
three four what the
can we all just take witness that this
package says very clearly six can we
count together
it's actually it's
would you complain yeah I bet you would
so I will too okay not happy about it
but just means we have to have more
fries all right some fries down I will
share these with the fam and I also need
some veg and some Fiber so I'm gonna
throw some carrots
snap peas
I am
I got some of this avocado hummus
so good great source of protein fiber
and healthy fats it's basically a
built-in hunger crushing combo yeah all
right folks let's recap we got protein
in our nugs we have lots of fiber rich
veg and our fruit going on healthy fats
in our avocado hummus and some fries on
the side for some extra carbs add and
choose the nug life the nug life chose
me
she's jealous okay kids are home from
school and they are already asking
what's for dinner and Charlie happens to
have some Italian Roots so naturally she
loves the pasta so basically what
inspired me to make pasta today is I
really like pasta and we love a carb
Queen so I was looking through her
YouTube channel and she has a great
looking recipe for pasta Ella vodka
which is low-key one of my favorite
pasta dishes of all time so we're gonna
do that because I will look for any
reason to have pasta and taco Caboose
let's do it we're gonna do a combo of
olive oil and butter nice little flavor
I know poppy smells good already
all right onion down and then some
garlic
that butter smells uh amazing Okay add a
quarter cup one two
three four comes out right
mix that in
a little pinch of chili that's probably
a lot guess the kids won't be eating
this yeah yeah oh where's my vodka not
sure it's big enough but it'll do
that's what she said
get that cooked off let's take a look
see at our water
oh she rolling
throw down some whole grain pasta
that's a mess
pasta
down some of our cooking water
[Music]
and
Charlie's recipe doesn't call for this
but I'm gonna throw in some spinach for
some extra fiber and color and I figured
we need a little extra protein so I've
got some chicken breasts that I just
grabbed off a rotisserie chicken little
cream
just to get everything nice and balanced
and like let's be real folks cream makes
everything
super delish that is a non-negotiable
lots of cheese
[Music]
this smells amazing so we got lots of
fiber in our whole grain Pasta Plus some
extra veg in there some protein in our
chicken and of course lots of fats with
the olive oil and the cheese and a
little cream in there and some vodka for
good measure
that Steam
Perfection Charlie my dear mwah Bueno
all right finally let's cap this day off
with some dessert so according to
Charlie's YouTube video she's a huge fan
of baking she loves doing cupcakes and
S'mores dip unfortunately I just don't
have a lot of patience for baking it has
been a long effing week and I just want
to get like something sweet in my mouth
at the end of the day without a whole
lot of fuss or muss or fuss or muss no
fuss and must what the is moss
anyways I figured why not just make a
s'mores on the gas stove I'm not sure if
that is safe but we can try it let's ask
Siri Siri which one do you push
that's what I just did Siri sure Siri
hey Siri why am I struggling
hey Siri
I know
hey Siri oh yeah that's why why hey Siri
is it safe to make marshmallows on a gas
stove can you roast marshmallows on a
gas stove as long as you have good
ventilation it is safe to roast
marshmallows on a gas burner so don't
come at me in the comments I checked
this I Googled it not sure how legit
this source is but we're gonna try it
this is the technique
oh
I'm too impatient
to not just burnt the out of it
let me know in the comments if you guys
like full-on
burnt or if you're more of like a golden
brown what kind of shade are you into
with your marshmallows
this is my this is my technique always
the more carcinogens the better that was
a good one
just got to get this little corner here
and we're good that's how I like it
folks don't judge me so I'm realizing
that a gas cooked marshmallow doesn't
taste the same as a campfire certainly
not
the carcinogens at least usually I
somewhat enjoy that so I think we're
going to go back to the stove top and
try for some more muted tones
oh
yeah I guess I could do that thanks
Brody help me oh I just want to get them
this is hard it's hard not to burn it
I'm just gonna do one of these oh yeah
this is working this is working for me
it's like casting a spell hocus pocus
give me dessert without burning down my
house the boy who lived
come to die Avada Kedavra I think this
is as good as we're gonna get with the
gas stove let's plate her up all right
oh yeah that's how you know you got a
good one the innards shigui I'm gonna
just like take this up a notch add a
little peanut butter smear because I
like peanut butter with my chocolate
I'm gonna squish
I'm gonna do this every night okay and
while I got the graham crackers out
because I love me a good graham cracker
bedtime snack I'm no spring chicken okay
I'm not Charlie so I know for my body
that I need a little more protein before
bed just to feel my best it's really
important for my digestion and also for
my sleep so I'm gonna do a little peanut
butter down we've got some more of that
full fat Greek yogurt right on top oink
some strawberries for some Fiber
a little almond action for some healthy
fats
we got our chocolate and marshmallow fix
and we've got a fruity option as well
together I feel like this is a really
balanced and delicious bedtime dessert
[Applause]
love it so that was like the most fun
day ever I got pasta I got nuggies I got
s'mores I got lucky charms like legit a
flashback to my 90s childhood and I'm
not mad about it yes I'm a little older
than Charlie so I would say this is more
sugar than I'm used to consuming in a
day I definitely don't even have the
palette for a lot of sweet Foods anymore
but I did try to find some ways to
balance it out to make it feel good for
my 35 year old body Honestly though this
is basically how I ate as a teenager and
I had the best healthiest relationship
with food and probably never felt better
in my life so I really applaud Charlie's
openness about her past eating disorder
and I also really appreciate her
modeling normal teenage eating nice job
team well folks I hope you enjoyed this
video please give it a thumbs up if you
liked it leave me a comment below on
Whose diet you'd like me to try next
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]